cet indice premier lieu ce soir
la méthode employée pour arrêter mars
indique que pour isoler murray voici les
explications
l'explosion bien réparé dans cette nuit
de vendredi à samedi dernier la centrale
de tchernobyl le sida n'apparaitrait
sénat je trouverais et que tu la sens
complètement ma salle des machines a
pris feu les flammes de 30 mètres
d'autres face à elle la vaillance des
ponts qui aujourd'hui célébrer par les
autorités sunnites
lebron qui s'enlise dans le bitume la
fumée les radiations
impossible de stopper cet enfer par les
moyens clairs au coeur du réacteur si
grave
vous serez qu'attiser la chance samedi
14h sur ses voûtes à présent réserver
des centaines d'autobus ont commencé
l'évacuation de 25 à 35 mille personnes
qui a du talent tout durait environ
quatre heures les journées tchernobyl
est une vivement mardi
8h10 moi je vous appelle à l'aide je
précise que je les dois est-allemand la
décision est finalement prise d'envoyer
des hélicoptères de l'armée
ils arguent 450 tonnes de sable d'argile
vous plongent tous bords le premier
shoot capable d'interrompre la fusion de
20 tonnes aujourd'hui
les autorités soviétiques ont affirmé
que la situation était maîtrisée et elle
risque de se compliquer
pour résoudre ce conflit cassou une
solution les robes où ils ont été
commandés au technicien allemand une
température ambiante de plus de 100
degrés au sol peuvent mettre un terme
définitif à cette catastrophe